au canada en europe et ailleurs les
frontières se referme autour du royaume
uni le nouveau variant de coved qui se
répand rapidement dans les îles
britanniques prennent une mauvaise
réputation celle d'une version mutante
hautement contagieuse est
potentiellement résistantes au nouveau
vaccin
mais pour l'instant ce ne sont que des
hypothèses il est vrai que le varia
s'est propagé rapidement
transmissibilité
selon boris johnson il serait 70% plus
transmissible
mais cette preuve scientifique reste à
faire il est possible qu'un facteur
humain est agit comme un puissant
multiplicateur du nouveau variant il
faut aussi s'assurer qu'il n'y a pas un
événement par exemple de super
transmission des rassemblements des
d'accueil beaucoup de problèmes dans
lesquels avec potentiellement le même
type de transmissibilité y aurait pu y
avoir en effet fondateur il n'a
également aucune preuve que ce va rien
qui n'est que l'une des très nombreuses
mutations du virus depuis son apparition
soit plus dangereux que les autres
en ce moment on n'y croit pas voir une
tendance ou que les personnes infectées
au rang des symptômes plus sévères que
la souche dean de one celle qui a
circulé à travers la ou les différentes
vallées entre le pion qui ont été qui
ont été dérivé de cette social quant à
une possible résistance contre les
nouveaux vaccins
c'est très peu probable selon les
experts
si c'était le cas à long terme on estime
que les vaccins comme ceux de pfizer
biotech et moderna pourrait rapidement
ajuster leur protection immunitaire
la bonne nouvelle
les britanniques ont très rapidement
identifié le coupable
analyser ses caractéristiques est relayé
l'information la communauté scientifique
au canada comme au québec on est déjà à
l'affût c'est extrêmement important
détruire toutes les mutations qui vont
apparaître qui peuvent paraître anodines
ou pas pour les comprendre il faut les
moniteurs et en temps réel c'est ça qui
est en train de faire et je trouve que
le travail qui a fait du royaume uni et
franchement extraordinaire ici normand
grondin radio canada montréal